hey everyone this is Steve Weintraub
with collider and I'm here in the
collider Studio sponsored by Saratoga
Spring Water huge thank you to Saratoga
because costs a lot of money to be here
and I appreciate our sponsors uh and I'm
here with the
[Laughter]
glass bottle the glass bottle is key you
know
drinking an avid bar of the century
laughs
thank you uh listen I'm actually
legitimately I'm I'm so looking forward
to seeing your movie here at Sundance uh
magazine dreams and I listen No One
including myself has seen the movie yet
and people watching this interview most
likely will not have seen the movie so
how have you actually been describing
the film to like friends and family
um
well the way we didn't describe it is
it's a movie about an amateur
bodybuilder uh
with dreams of bodybuilding super
stardom
and we follow his trajectory from
someone
um
who whose entire life is centered around
becoming
a superstar in the bodybuilding Sport
and the bodybuilding world and then some
of the obstacles he faces along the way
Jonathan
I'm you have been doing some exceptional
work recently and been offered some
really great scripts what was it about
this project that said oh I need to do
this
uh I read the script and uh immediately
thought
um
there's a lot of Secrets here you know
um I like to
I do I try to do work that uh
illuminates
and kind of brings things to the
Forefront and the story of Killian
Maddox in the world of magazine dreams
uh is a world
populated with people who have been uh
rebuked in many ways
um
that really pulled me
that idea that there's a whole group of
folks that have been put aside by
society and how we cope with that and
I aligned with that in some ways and um
felt very seen in that
um as the viewers will see uh Killian
deals with that
um
uh
push away that
invisibility issue
on multiple accounts in many different
ways so um yeah I mean
yeah it's wicked
yeah so that's that that's what got me
you know that's what got me uh Haley I
am a big fan of your work and I am
curious similar question
um what was it about this what can you
say about your character and what was it
about this story and script that said I
I want to do this
I read the script and I I really
connected with it I I had a conversation
with Elijah that really excited me his
vision for the film
um and of course I was really excited to
work to for the potential to work with
Jonathan because he's incredible I've
seen the film I've been really lucky I
was lucky I I got to have the film
screen for me last night and
it's honestly like such a I don't mean
to embarrass you you were so humble uh
this is in a tour de force performance
and the virtuoso directing
I'm setting the bar very high right now
so um that kind of terrifies me but in
terms of my character Jesse um for me I
think that this film is is a cinematic
poem for the underdog
um and like I love what you said about
illumination
um
I think Jessie is a character who also
is is accustomed to to being rejected
she's
incredibly empathetic and and humble and
and I think you know really excited
about this idea of connecting with
another human being I mean quite Getty
and there were a lot of qualities that I
saw in myself
um sort of heightened qualities she's
character that's very shy so this idea
of
just making this connection with another
human being there it's such a lovely
sweet scene that they have together and
and
um that was that was that was why I
wanted to do the film
so one of the things uh the photo that's
been released has you basically doing a
bodybuilding pose and you are clean
you've clearly worked out and I'm
curious how much time did you have from
getting the the information oh we're
going to start shooting to saying oh I
really gotta hit the gym and how did
this film play into also Creed Three
because you obviously have to train for
that as well
uh yeah so I guess the question is like
the invisible work began
I mean right right at the height of
coven you said I got the script uh
October 2020. yeah so
wherever we were in that yeah you know
and I was held up in uh in New Mexico uh
reading it and um
that's the subconscious work you know
but all of a sudden I started yeah
that's that's a long time ago
um so
yeah you don't have that much runway you
know
um and so subconsciously I'm thinking oh
I'm I'm gonna do this bodybuilder and
film you know at some point in life
either I'm gonna be doing this
um
so I began to think about it dream about
it
um at that point I was shooting um The
Harder They Fall Right
the question to uh uh Creed and Damien
um
yeah I was I was training the whole time
you know it was it's a it's a Killian is
the Apex of uh uh a king uh Damien
Killian that's the order they were shot
um and so the process began you know
that long ago uh for the uh the training
routine altered from Roll to roll
um the diet really changed to come uh
Killian uh can I just ask you real fast
yeah were you an a-hole to be around
when you were in full training mode
because you couldn't eat anything or did
were you able to like okay okay here it
is
um I was not an [__] I got to be more
myself right because I am believe I am
quite introverted don't like don't
really and love people
I love people uh but all three of us I
think you know are are very introverted
and so in bodybuilding I found the role
um an occupation that really allowed me
to like really be myself you know I'm a
Virgo so Aesthetics are important yeah I
mean so I'm like this is not a problem
to be you know what I mean
um and and and it was the uh it was the
bodybuilding it was all these things
that connected me directly to the you
know to the piece and so uh I was very
happy while I was shooting it
um and I ate a lot it works it works
different ways with different people
some people can't eat so you have to eat
a lot I had to eat a lot and so I was
probably most grumpy meal six
8 15.
pacing around my apartment yeah I mean
like just [__] chicken these rice you
know just like trying to get it down I'm
I was very grumpy then but after that I
was uh I was laughing yeah and we made
sure we moved the schedule around his
eating yeah
because you don't want to you don't want
to schedule a scene when Jonathan's
grumpy that's not fun for anyone okay so
Elijah um uh a little bit of a jokey
question but your last film you had
Timothy chalamet before he blew up and
obviously for your second film you have
Jonathan Majors do you think he has a
career after your movie Jonathan
you know maybe if he sha if he shaves
that thing down on his face and
of course I think Jonathan's probably
the most interesting and exciting and
talented actor in his his generation
right now and I'm just lucky to have him
really
someone's throat is being cleared
Haley as well but we we were on the
subject of Jonathan
I'll get to you next Haley
um
a career and then some I think he'll be
um I think you can do anything you're
asking me to do and I think you know any
director who's lucky enough to work with
him should be careful what they ask for
because they're going to get exactly
that and then maybe a little more and
hopefully the movie in the
and and the director can handle it
because he's going to give it to you
that's for sure uh for people that have
not seen Cyrano I'm going to talk about
Haley for a second or recently sir that
was wicked Sierra knows you're those
Wicked yeah I I I love that movie and
you are so great in it so because I
haven't seen magazine dreams yet I can't
talk about your performance I'm just
going to say if you haven't seen Cyrano
or recently till
um just to cite two recent things
um you know she's okay
Wicked you know yeah um so I am curious
about the making of the film though
because
um this isn't a Marvel movie you are not
you don't have some crazy budget so how
much time did you actually have for the
shoot and one ended up being the
toughest part to pull off with the time
and budget you had
yeah that's a good question
um we shot it in 24 days
which was it was well look it doesn't
sound like a lot and it's not a lot but
hopefully some of that intensity and
focus found its way onto the screen
because we had no choice but to work
that way
are are
carrying the entire film so I think it's
like you know when you have it's an
ensemble but he carries this film and I
think that makes 24 days much more
achievable
you probably disagree yeah but you had a
lot of locations we had a lot of
location but it does it helps when you
have one man to keep coming back to and
you're in it with him and you're in the
trenches with him and we would shoot an
entire day and then on the ride home
yeah as we're driving back the phone
would ring and it'd be Jonathan and we
would talk about the next day's work
because yeah
I know I know I know I know I know but
what do you think about this tomorrow
it's about tomorrow's work what do you
think about this and buy them just yeah
bro yeah bro yeah bro I think that we're
literally workshopping we we shot it 24
days 24 7. you know like but isn't that
what you have to do when you have that
kind of a schedule that's what you
should do in general
to be immersed to like 24 24 7. yeah
yeah I think if we had you know I think
the first budget we did the line
producers like this movie wants to be 45
days
and we couldn't we couldn't afford to do
it that way but I do think if we had 45
days to do it I don't know if the movie
would have turned out the way it did
there was an energy on set you know like
like it I mean not many people have gone
to a bodybuilding competition yeah I
mean like not many people I I hadn't
gone any up until you know go time
uh it but it it is intense I mean I mean
the energy is intense I mean
the way the way we they won the way we
hit the set the the we look like we look
like bodybuilders we were focused you
know it was in the whole crew was like
oh it's like that
feels very documentary yes yes style yes
yes capturing real real real real [__]
yeah from the from the human beings to
the technology and you just think of the
action of Contracting muscle it can only
stay there for a few seconds and then it
burns out yeah that's right and I think
there's something about that that uh
puts itself to the movie so for all
three of you and again I don't know how
how much are in the film so um but I'm
curious when you're looking at the 24
Day schedule for each of you what was
the day you had circled that said oh
this is going to be a real day we had 11
pages and that was yeah yeah there's a
scene they have together at a
on a date
um that's 11 pages of dialogue and that
was probably the one that we all lost a
bit of Sleepover there was a few of them
that kept us up at night but that was
probably the big one
there were a few I mean
every it was war it was wartime every
day wasn't it you know but there was uh
for me there was a moment of uh
competition
right bodybuilder he does competition no
spoilers here
um that was the day because I was
training I was doing the the work we
were doing the work and there's a part
that Bynum couldn't help me with and I
didn't have the wonderful Haley to be my
assistant partner is literally going in
competition the posing the the what they
call drying what we call drying out you
know all of that talk about crazy if
there was a moment where it was like oh
I'm not feeling I'm feeling crazy uh was
when you've I've pulled out all the
water and then this insane man wants me
to
right and it was not that long shot that
incredibly long shot those days were um
yes those days were were intense because
the body was at a level where like
you're only supposed to hold that for
three hours and he's supposed to go have
a hamburger but I couldn't because the
next day we're shooting after that is
training yeah I mean so uh that day I
had circles because I was working with
uh Bynum I was working with my trainers
I was working with my nutritionist I
mean everybody was working you know that
was that was D-Day you know yeah I can't
first of all I can't imagine doing that
and I don't think people realize who
watch movies that when like for example
in like top gun Maverick when they're
doing that beach scene like they were
training and specifically building up to
get those shots yeah you know and but
like when you're making a shot like that
you're you're training for that moment
and it's not like a natural thing you
have a team of people to help you
achieve that look
there's something to be said to what he
said he said I thought the right
response is it is like it's mostly you
but like there's people to help you
yes
yes okay yes I want you to get down and
do 300 push-ups and she's gonna help you
do it I'm working I'm helping you yeah
you caught what I was getting that yeah
yeah
let me do interviews too often so this
is one of those jokes no no no you're
absolutely right it takes a village to
make the film but and to get those shots
the beautiful thing about bodybuilding
uh and I sincerely mean it is the
isolation you know because no one can
make you make no one can make you eat
that food you know I can look at a guy
now a bodybuilder and go I see where you
cheated I see where your uh Integrity
broke you know or I see how hurt you
were you know I can see that in
somebody's body yeah I mean and nobody
can Aid you and shove that food down
your down your throat or make you lift
that weight you know we had this thing
that we would say on set I would be
commenting to myself Big Rap Big Rap Big
Rap Big Rap which means this was it this
is gonna take everything you had in this
moment and sometimes it was looking at
that plate of food being like okay big
rep bro just get that down just get it
down get back the set and go yeah I mean
um
yeah and some of the food he was eating
was not just offset it was
part of the scene oh yeah yeah as a role
in the camera and he would actually step
away between takes and yeah clean out
yeah sure I I I'm uh are you a fan of of
eating scenes on camera because I don't
know if I can hear I don't think anyone
is I
I love all of it yeah I love all of it
uh uh it depends on what it is yeah
thumbtacks what yeah good swallow let's
talk about let's talk about let's talk
about it we can film look at Phil yeah I
guess that's uh yeah I guess you don't
eat everything no
so the editing room let's talk about
that real quick it's ultimately where
the film comes together and I'm curious
how this film changed in the editing
room in ways you did not expect
um not not
too much I think
um
well I shouldn't say not too much but we
we head into the editing room feeling
like we had pretty good footage to work
with but once we got in there we didn't
look at the script ever again hmm I
think by the time you get into the edit
room the script
um
it doesn't really matter much anymore
because the footage is not what you're
working with and the footage should be
the guide and what we found early on was
it's best to just sort of swim with the
current and let the movie tell you what
it wants to be and we were lucky enough
to have incredible performances across
the board to choose from so then it just
became calibrating what we wanted and
there was there was a little bit of
restructuring in the in the second half
um because certain scenes would take on
a different meaning depending on where
they were ordered in the movie
um
but it was a pretty smooth editing
process really and then it just became
about what music sounds best
uh you're in the here you're in the
Sundance Film Festival and uh one of the
biggest in the world
um again congratulations when did you
find out you were part of it and how
long did you have to hold the secret
oh
um I I think I was called days before
Thanksgiving someone from Sundance
called me and told me we were in I hold
I held the secret for about 15 seconds
yeah I call my mom and I let her know
when did you guys find out and did you
were you able to like not tell you know
what I mean did you have to hold it for
a few weeks or
I mean I'm in good practice of keeping
uh Secrets around work so I I was just
uh
it was something it's just like it was
like a gift you know I mean you kind of
just want to hold it you know and
I did we spoke about it and that was a
good you know but but I I held it until
I think it was announced yeah I mean
yeah
I'm a terrible Secret Keeper like
anyone I ever buy a Christmas present
for knows what it is before they open it
on Christmas I don't know why I wrap
them anymore
um I think I found out on a Friday and
then I told like internally my my family
my daughter who's like what are you
talking about
um and yeah and then I think I kept it
a secret until like yeah it came out a
question for the two of you but it was
so unexpected it was like came out of
nowhere and I was like wow this is so
great that's so incredible
congratulations yeah not low
expectations but it's just like you know
you do a film and you kind of move on
you forget about it and of course you
don't because you you're in the editing
room making your magic but for me you're
like you know
waving mud off boots and then you get a
call and you're like your films the film
you were part of go is going to Sundance
uh individual I have an individual
question for the two of you in an
individual question for you if you could
get the financing to make anything you
want what would you make and why
I have something I want to do next I
can't share it right now I understand
but I have something in mind is it
something you wrote it it will be
something I've written got it I
understand there is some Source material
but it's based off something very old
that I'm going to take a little bit from
and
adapt it here and there to make it um
fit the story I have in mind
and I do have an actor in mind for it
you might be able to guess who that is
I'm not going to pressure you by by
saying the person's name who's sitting
next to you
um for the two of you uh you guys have
both done such great work and I'm
curious if someone hasn't seen something
that you if someone if if someone has
not seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why
and you can say this I'm just curious if
there's something
um my eighth grade choir performance uh
my talent show uh no I would I would
definitely say swallow probably
um swallow came out during the pandemic
like right uh during the pandemic so
that was unfortunate
um
and yeah I think that was difficult for
the momentum and to find an audience
um and and uh yeah yeah that's it
probably have an answer for that either
you know
anything
um
I don't know man they're all they're all
it's all the long throw you know that is
that that is that oh I know I'd like to
see my footage from Terence Malik film I
would like yeah yeah I would like to
which film which film was it
um a film that I was cut from he's cut
to everyone yeah it's interesting
because and I I want to say I forget who
it was but someone thought they were the
lead in the Finn Red Line went to the
premiere yeah yeah I think it was
Christopher Plummer wasn't it no oh
that's the that's a new world two of us
just gave the right answer yeah and one
of us didn't and you heard it clearly no
but but seriously like he thought he was
the he thought he was the lead and then
he went to the premiere and he was
basically not in the movie I've been
told uh uh to prepare myself uh that
that yeah I've been told to prepare
myself in regards to magazine dreams so
you're no longer in the movie I hate to
break it to you now on collider but
right I'm not worried Jonathan I
definitely have to ask you um you know
I'm a fan of uh of these Marvel films
and I'm just curious I know you're not
going to tell me anything about the
future but what is it like being part of
a universe where you are going to be
such a central character for the next
few years like a it's a guaranteed gig
but B it is like I mean you are a very
big Focus um and I'm just curious what
it's like for you
are you excited by it is it you know
well it's funny man we were coming in
here and a bunch of guys who you know
like like some movies and and a lot of
them like the the MCU movies
um
it's exciting the fact that
think about theater right you do a play
you have no idea if someone's coming to
that show yeah I mean you work your ass
off you have no idea like okay the
tickets don't really matter you know you
already check into different ecosystem
you know you're hoping people are gonna
come see the work you've done in that
space in that black box for that long
right you're hoping it's gonna happen
um with the MCU you know and and with
Kang
um there is such a
a beautiful
sensation knowing that uh the work that
myself and my collaborators do
um is going to reach people
um
that responsibility
um is something I honor and something I
I really take on you know
um
there's 50 guys outside all those outfit
those guys are going to see you know uh
quantumania yeah I mean
that's beautiful you know what I mean
like that a guaranteed impact you know
is something that you go okay yeah you
know but no I was gonna say one of the
things though and I could be wrong is
that you're playing the same character
but it could be versions of the same
character so you're not possibly the
same I don't know actually I mean as an
actor I mean like no no spoilers here
like like uh Kang Kang has we can take
it there uh but Kang has variants you
know I mean
um
there's you know there's always variance
um I I I'm King so whatever comes
through comes through you know what I
mean and uh
yeah it's neat well one of one of the
things though and and like people don't
really talk about it but like a movie
like this magazine dreams there's going
to be people that are Marvel fans that
are going to seek this movie out
specifically because they've seen you in
a Marvel movie and they want to see you
know or someone saw you until or uh
swallow and said oh I want to see her
next movie so I mean can you you know
what I mean like that's obviously not a
reason you cast Jonathan but it's an
added benefit that more people will see
it yeah it doesn't hurt at all it really
but it it it's great because I think it
will bring more eyeballs to a movie that
otherwise might not have been seen
um with that said it it is not the
reason I cast either of them I cast them
because I think they were just perfect
for the roles that we wrote and I think
they embodied
um the spirit of the character and their
actors I had been wanting to work with
and was grateful to work with and the
fact that they now have like these big
franchises that are bringing attention
to them
all the better but um I mean that's the
beauty that came from that's to be about
Sundance about independent film and
about uh
I mean what you and I do as as being in
front of the camera you know that like
having having either one of us in the
film at whatever point in our career
then brings people to a different type
of story you know what I mean
um that's beautiful that then helps us
tell similar stories like you know a
magazine dream you know
um with from other points of view other
Vantage points if you if you get folks
you know that have I mean it's also a
different muscle to be honest yeah I
mean like
the speed of it it's different yeah I
mean the intensity of it can be
different you know unless you hold it
steady you know
um
but yeah that's
I'm rambling but it's a
yes I am rambling
no it's true you know you you have
infinite amount of days making a mobile
film and you have 24 days to make
magazine dreams and 18 days to make
swallow like it's a different beat it's
it's all beautiful
um I'm curious for the two of you from
when you first started when you first
got you first stepped on a film set I'm
sure you prepared a certain way and now
that you've done a number of roles I'm
curious how has your
how have you changed when you're on a
set and you're doing a role from when
you first started or do you have a very
similar process and way of doing things
well I think I just got more you grow up
you know and you know I I don't I don't
use it as a specific acting technique or
any of that stuff
I read acting books constantly that's a
fact
um was there one specifically that you
want to point out no
I read them all I read I read them all
you know uh uh but then you realize for
me it went from like oh you know I have
a way of living and and I went to these
schools and and I have a point of view
on acting right and that's what I'm
that's what I'm doing and then that
point of view becomes it's more of a
lifestyle it's like if there's an
approach you know I think I have a I I
can I now have more
um outward confidence I had the internal
confidence starting out but now there's
more outward confidence to to hold the
line and create the space around me you
know that though that the world of the
play and the world of the character now
expands further than me and that the if
I if I can make it go from here to here
to here to here
this is the thing you know what I mean
it it actually is funny it actually
devolves from acting it just becomes
living
and so that that I mean a lot of that
happened in drama school yeah I mean by
the time I hit uh uh Mr Gus Van Zant
um
we kind of that was already kind of
percolating so the the
as as I matured it just became don't be
afraid of the thing that's already there
you know lean into that
I
um confidence building
um experience uh working with Incredible
actors that teach you a lot um working
with Incredible directors
um and then also like understanding the
nature within to lend to characters
um and less thinking I think and more
being less acting and and more living
um
and then
you know I think it's about these kind
of great myths
um
I don't know I was
making a film recently and it's like
archetypical Journeys and I think that's
what you mean is like what is this what
is the greater
um universal truth of of the character
and how can I how can I tap into those
truths in myself
to be a to just to be uh to contribute
to to hit to contribute to to be in
service of of not just the character but
the story
um so that the audience can can find
their truths within within that
um and and hold the character within
themselves
I really want to thank you for your work
in general and uh just because I really
enjoy watching the two of you on screen
I am so looking forward to seeing your
movie I want to thank the three of you
for coming in and a huge thank you again
to Sarasota because uh uh you know
Saratoga I said it wrong and I'm sorry I
apologize but I really want to give a
huge thank you to them and listen thank
you so much for coming in and I really
hope you have a fantastic Sundance thank
you very much good to see you